at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking no personal question no I'm a
cybernetic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by thrive market if
you're anything like me you care a lot
about the food you put into your body in
fact I think it's much more important
than exercise the problem is that good
food can be extremely expensive but it
doesn't have to be thrive market which
is one of the fastest growing startups
in the health space right now is like
Costco for everything healthy an online
shopping club offering the best brands
and groceries at 25 to 50% off of retail
prices ship nationally for free it's
awesome there are a ton of slow carp
friendly items that I recommend in the
4-hour body you can easily filter
everything by your preferences whether
you're paleo gluten-free vegan raw
non-gmo vegetarian veterinarian whatever
so go to thrive market comm forward
slash Tim and check it out you can get a
free two month trial and 25% off your
first order when you sign up for a
membership if you sign up it's fifty
nine ninety five per year which is only
$5 a month at the very least go there
and check out the avocado Mayo they have
which is amazing not only that for every
paying member thrive gives a free
membership to a low-income family
veteran or teacher which is awesome and
helps level the playing field so you can
get ripped while you're doing some good
also never pay full price for healthy
food again
check it out thrive market.com forward
slash Tim to start your free two month
trial and get 25% off your first order
what you have to lose nothing go check
it out
avocado Mayo it's read thrive market.com
forward slash Tim
hello my little Mogwai this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show where each
episode it is my job to deconstruct a
world-class performer take a peek under
the hood inside their brain tease out
the thinking and the frameworks the
tools tricks you can use in this episode
we have well first of all waves in the
background waves lapping the deck next
to me and I have had a change of
location to a more Beach based
environment but we also have professor
Lisa Randall I'm so excited about this
one she is at Lera Randall on Twitter Li
RA Randall who researches particle
physics and cosmology at Harvard where
she is a professor of theoretical
physics professor Randall was the first
tenured woman in the Princeton Physics
Department and then the first tenured
female theoretical physicist at Harvard
she is a killer and the best way
possible in autumn 2004 she was the most
cited theoretical physicist of the
previous five years to then seven
Randall was named one of Time Magazine's
100 most influential people under the
section for scientists and thinkers
Randall was given this honor for her
work regarding the evidence of a higher
dimension and we get into dimensions we
get into time we get into hidden
dimensions and all sorts of fascinating
things in this conversation she's also a
very adept rock climber among many other
things and has a lot of involvement with
music she's written several
mind-expanding books the newest of which
is dark matter in the dinosaurs subtitle
the astounding interconnectedness of the
universe and if you want a semi
psychedelic experience viewing the world
through a new lens without imbibing any
substances or risking incarceration the
book is well worth checking out I love
reading about physics it is a a pet
obsession of mine many of you know I
have as one of my heroes richard fineman
and we go all over the place i know not
of what I speak when it comes to physics
but I do enjoy speaking with someone
like Professor Randall and I should make
a couple of notes the first is that we
had some connection difficulties so that
sound quality may be challenging and I
ask you to bear with me please don't
bitching moan excessively on the
internet about it
because
here's the thing with very busy guests
sometimes it is a go or no-go decision
that means we can do an interview with
suboptimal sound quality which i think
is perfectly fine for most people quite
frankly or we can not do the interview
at all because schedules need to match
so please bear with us I appreciate your
patience I still think that you'll be
able to get a whole hell of a lot out of
it and I think 99 plus percent of it is
audible so you should be able to get
tons and then last but not least I'll
repeat professor Randall has a question
at the end and she'd love to hear from
you so please ping her on Twitter at
Lera Randall so named Lisa Randall but
on Twitter it's Lera Randall at Li ra ra
n da LLL and with that please enjoy my
conversation with professor Lisa Randall
professor Randall welcome to the show
thanks for having me here I am so
excited to dig in today and to talk for
many many reasons we have mutual friends
of course but beyond that I have been
simultaneously fascinated by physics and
embarrassed by my lack of knowledge of
physics for a very long time I went to
Princeton undergrad became obsessed with
Richard Fineman bought surely must be
joking mr. Fineman and then his his many
other books and I'm hoping that we can
dig into your areas of expertise but
also perhaps just answer some very basic
questions that have led me to have a lot
of insecurities related to the sciences
so that's that's a long intro but I'm
happy to have you here actually
mentioned this the end of my book is
this really funny because whenever you
tell people you do physics everyone
feels compelled to tell you their
attitude or relationship to physics in a
way that that you know they don't for
example if you say I'm a lawyer they
don't feel like they have to tell you
how they feel about the law they have to
tell you whether they like it or they
hate it or they're interested or not
it's very funny well I feel like I
pleading ignorance upfront as always
good insurance policy
from waiting kind of deep into the yeah
plausible deniability if there's a
likelihood I'll drown in my own
stupidity later that I want to put on
the life vest of plausible deniability
first but when you're at a cocktail
party or any type of engagement you meet
someone and they ask you what do you do
how do you answer that question you know
obviously I'm going to tell them in most
circumstances and press for physics and
what I study
then I study the fundamental nature of
matter I study the universe how the
universe has evolved the nature of space
but I don't necessarily go into all of
that sometimes if I want to make myself
life a little bit easier I'll just tell
them that I write about physics and then
eventually they'll ask me what I write
about and then it will come back to the
fact that I'm doing research too but
it's really interesting is one of the
things for me when I started writing
about physical addition obviously
tutoring research is really the primary
thing was I found that it's so much
easier to talk to people about it
because people understand writing more
than they understand research or they
think they do at the very least many
more friends were writers than I had
appreciated like once I started writing
I realized oh well I have a lot of
friends who write all of these closeted
authors come out of the woodwork though
they were actual authors it's just I had
never actually made the list
I realized what it could put sizeable
fraction of my friends were writers now
I'm looking at your bio and I've spent a
lot of time looking at your bio and I I
have to admit that I could really use
some definition so you whole search
particle physics and cosmology at
Harvard where you're professor of
theoretical physics so I'd like to start
with the basic basics physics like what
is or what are physics
of course that's a question that gene is
at some level the time but really we're
trying to understand the fundamental
nature of matter what stuff is made of
and how it works sort of the physical
processes by which things happen I mean
there's other levels at which we can
look at things we can look at them
biologically we can look at biological
processes or we can look at cyclic
process but ultimately we're looking at
the substrate we're looking at the
matter from which all these other things
emerge what is stuff made of and how do
we put it together to get the kinds of
things that we observed and what are the
forces that act on that matter to
produce what we see so these are these
are questions that people have had for a
very very long time
what is theoretical physics and what is
the other is the alternative means that
I can do my work force essentially a
pencil and paper
I'm not running the experiments with
which will test the ideas and running
these firms I provide data I might
interact with experimenters into quite
often and say this would be an
interesting thing to look at you know I
look at the data so it's not that I
don't care about what happens with
experiments or observations in the case
of astronomy but I am NOT doing those
things myself I'm thinking about how we
can tie it all together in a theoretical
sense how do we make sense of what it is
that we see what are the fundamental
underlying connections what are the
forces what is there what is what is
cosmology and what is I'm stumbling over
the weather physics is a plural or
singular I guess people just say is like
chemistry it's so it's like it's a
finger the same way chemistry isn't good
got it
but what cosmology is is the study of
the evolution of the universe how the
universe has has become what it is today
how it's changing the universe as a
whole how does the university fall what
particle physics is is
what is the fundamental nature of matter
if you keep digging deeper and deeper
what is the basic stuff of which things
are made and what are the forces that
act at that level and when we talk of
and don't worry I'm not going to seem
that was completely satisfactory so like
if we're you know we're talking on a
computer it's made up of stuff it's you
know everyone knows is made of the
molecules which are made up of atoms
those atoms are made up of nuclei with
electrons around them the nuclei are
made up of protons and neutrons which
are made up in turn of quarks particles
called quartz which are held together by
gluons so this is a particle physicist
I'll study things at the level of quarks
and gluons and electrons and the proton
it produces electromagnetism and I'll
say R is there an understanding of why
those are the particles why they have
the masses they do
are they fundamental are there even
smaller in some sense particles of which
these guys are made so we're trying to
understand what are the basic elements
of matter and how they're related got it
thank you and I've so many questions up
but I want to turn back the clock a
little bit because there's the current
state I know you know it just so happens
and I didn't time it purposefully this
day but today is Back to the Future day
and apparently I just perfect very
appropriate and it turns out that a lot
of my fans think I look exactly like
Biff jr. who wears a chrome helmet so
people can look that up but I had a lot
more hair so yeah turning back the clock
is always something I've wanted to be
able to do but if we look at and please
feel free to correct any of this I you
were the first tenured woman in the
Princeton Physics Department and the
first tenured female theoretical
physicists at Harvard well your sister I
believe is in computer science is that
right okay you're both women in
male-dominated fields how did you both
end up a scientist
what were the
was the formation of both of you or
speaking to your personal experience as
scientists well joke my sister she who's
four and a half PS anger gets mad at me
because people will ask me were their
scientists and my family and I'll say no
because you know when you're a kid and
your sister younger sister is four and
half years younger you don't and we
weren't trying to affect them so but
when they asked her she will say yes my
own you know my older sister did sign
but having said that I mean she's
absolutely brilliant and of course you
know outstanding scientists today but
you know it's it's just say exactly what
it is I mean when people ask me you know
I always joke only half jokingly they
wasn't properly socialized you know and
I I like challenges I thought if this is
something I might want to do I should
try to do it and see how it works out
but you know it's funny because people
are much more open about talking about
this it's an issue um you know I mean
it's not like I didn't notice that I was
the only woman in my class or actually
sometimes he was even worse than that I
there would be a few women in the class
and by the end of it I'd be the only one
and you know it's not like you don't
notice that but you know it's not a
defining feature I mean I was taking the
same class as I was saying the same
thing um you know it wasn't something so
you know it's something actually you
know sort of it you get more senior
you're more aware of it and the context
of how it affects a relationship with
colleagues but at the time I was just
trying to do my work really if we look
at some of the specifics for instance
again I'm just pulling from the cliff
notes here but the did the Hampshire
College summer studies and mathematics
come before high school was that during
high school actually it's really
interesting that you asked about that I
actually I mean it's I'm really happy
you brought that up um I actually did
that when I was in high school and you
know it was at Hampshire College and so
it was actually a fun place to be us
Western math but it was you know
essentially math camp but it sounds
totally embarrassing but for us mellow
just to people it was actually a really
fun thing
to do to get out of New York City and to
go there but joking aside um I actually
feel very strongly that these summer
programs are really important you know I
was at one NSF made National Science
Foundation meaning where they were
asking about things we can do and I
actually raised the bat I thought having
these summer science or math programs
can be really important that was really
interesting to me because I think you
know the other woman in the room felt
the same way and I also think it's
something that actually helps with mine
are it helps with disadvantaged students
because it's a way to get outside
whatever is your environment I mean I'd
love to believe that we can just you
know instantly improve all high schools
all over the country but we're not going
to do that right away and so the idea
that the best students or the best
trends in a particular area or it
streams with a lot of interest in an
area have the opportunity to meet other
excellent students and have fun with it
and see you know and not be defined by
their environment I mean this is a you
know it's just it was Hampshire College
I mean people came from all over and I
actually think that's a very valuable
experience I agree
yeah the the translation of location and
that social circle or there's just the
the context that may be hindering or
helping depending on on the person I've
also found really valuable so I did I
hesitate to say this because it implies
I actually know something about it but I
actually went to a summer camp for
physics at Northfield Mount Hermon in
high school and then went two months now
now in fairness it wasn't because I was
excelling and trying to graduate in
three years it's because I wasn't going
to graduate if I didn't take satisfy my
position so it's really nice I mean I
you know I was talking to someone I mean
one of the problems or good things or
bad things I don't know how you want to
do it but it's a defining feature of the
educational system is that if you don't
do the subject at the same rate you're
going to be in trouble and it's
something in the sciences and a math
it's a much more serious issue I think
you know if you fall behind in a physics
class or in a math class
you're basically never going to catch up
and the rest of the time is wasted so
too
have these opportunities to sort of
catch up I mean I think it's very
important oh I I totally agree and you
know it's just this is maybe a UH I
wasn't planning on bringing this up but
it's it's an interesting example of
early influences and I'm not gonna let
go of you the story of you and your
sister we're gonna come back to that but
in 10th grade my brother my younger
brother and I went to the same school
and in 10th grade we both had two
different math teachers and my math
teacher was actually really and she was
she was a good teacher but she was she
was very kind of embittered through the
academic process and I ended up
disliking math as a result so I actually
went to Princeton partially because
there was no math requirement but that
led to the require necessity of going to
physics summer camp so it kind of blew
up in my face in that respect it wasn't
it was it was a necessary but not
sufficient criterion but my brother on
the other hand had a wonderful
experience in tenth grade same year uh
neither of us were predisposed to math
and he's now you know he is PhD in
statistics always get a finishing his
PhD in statistics absolutist so free for
you and your sister if you look back and
what did your parents do when you were
growing up in Queens I believe it was
right yeah so I should I mean just for
the record I actually have two sisters
okay um both his sister who actually was
um learning disabled at some level and
she was my older sister um so just to be
clear of course and I think it's one of
the reasons I was very aware of you know
just how you learn and and they had
education a lot I did fill level but I
was lucky you know that I was able to
learn things and so I felt sort of
responsibility to really learn because
of that I thought you know I've given
this ability and I didn't want I just
thought it wasn't really fair and I
thought I should be able to use it I
think part of the
was frankly you know just taking it
seriously well at least our studies you
know it's not that it was all easy and I
actually had to argue quite a bit to go
to Stuyvesant High School because it
would we meant I had to take public
transportation in the 70s to get to high
school from Queens to Manhattan um so
but I think there was a sense in which
you know they did just value learning
and so you pass oh yeah so and I think
what did they do professionally so no
there was a teacher and she stopped when
she had kids my father he's studying and
everybody was ourselves but he's
excelled really so they weren't
scientist by any means a lot of people
asking my parents were scientists and
they weren't I mean it really was
something that I decided I really
decided for myself it was something I
was interested in and want to do I mean
I think both my sister and I had like we
really like math I mean I you know I
also grew up you know I was went to
school you know start school in the 60s
I shouldn't give away my but it's easier
to look up on Wikipedia you know and it
was this time of great uncertainty you
know I mean my joke is my first day of
school didn't exist you know we had
school strikes and all of that and I
think I liked you know this sort of
certainty of sort of math and science
and having answers right of course you
know when you do research you realize
it's all about not having answers but
there was you know but no matter how bad
the teachers were there still was gonna
be like a right and wrong answer of
everything and you know you and you
could still learn it on your own if you
needed to and um and I think that was
probably one of the things that I mean
it's not you know I like reading I liked
all sorts of things but I think I did
like that sort of sense of security that
you have voicing with numbers and or
with math and and it was fun I mean it
was fun to play with
you know like puzzle solving I think my
inner sister does too and um and so I
think you know like I said I mean she
was a lot younger so I really felt like
I was sort of just saying these things
but um but and it's not like I knew
right away I mean I remember in junior
high school very decidedly thinking I
would be a lawyer why you know why a
lawyer you know I think I just I'm
and I had a very idealistic sense of you
know finding the truth and our game for
the truth and I wanted you know I don't
know I like um I like getting the right
you know the right outcome so it seemed
seem like something that would be
worthwhile and um you know I think was
before the days that jr. eyes with
students not having about corporate law
but and then I went to high school in
which a Stuyvesant in York and I just
also want to say how important I think
really good public schools are I mean it
was a public school that I got you by
public transportation which honestly was
a pain but I got there you know I just
take a bus to the subway but but there
was a way of getting there and um and I
just um you know I took my first physics
course and I liked it and that you know
I couldn't really see myself necessarily
during math I mean my entire life but I
thought it'd be interesting to try to
understand the world you know through
mouth and um you know there was never an
option for me to be an experimenter I
always was gonna be a theoretical
physicist if I did it like wise I was
you know um I just like the sort of game
playing I like the sort of solving
problems and I have no patience and I'm
very messy that's funny it's kind of
reminds me of a question that I was
asked when I was researching cooking for
the 4-hour chef and they said do you
like to fold your socks or your
underwear and I said kind of why and
they said because that would mean you're
going to be good as a baker
if you're gonna be a chef there's like
the messy folks who are impatient the
the conversation with your parents to go
to high school and take public
transportation tell me about that how
did that go what was your argument well
you know I I actually did like I took
the test and I mean it it sounds like
I'm bragging but I mean you're I'm
answering your question I do I really
did one of the best of the test I get in
the city and I you know I felt like I
kind of had a right to go you know and I
just really want you know
the school's amount of neighborhood work
okay but you know there were actually
issues coming up and they were actually
racial issues in the neighborhood and
you know high school was kind of a mess
nearby at the time I mean it wasn't
terrible people did find that you know I
really wanted to go to a good school and
frankly what I really wanted was to get
out of Queens - I am you know I found I
wasn't that happy there my thumb it was
like everyone was supposed to be the
same and you know and I was right about
that when I went to my henna and like
people had you know could be individuals
it was valued and I really loved that so
just you know it was sort of a special
experience as much as anything that I
really liked being able to get into
Manhattan every day but you know and and
but you know there were a ridiculous
deal by to me like um you know I was
actually the first woman captain of math
team but math team that at 8 o'clock in
the morning so that meant leaving really
early but my mother didn't want me to go
out in the dark and you know it's 70s
there were lots of bad things happening
in New York but you know the fact is I
had to get to school so they were
compromises to be made but but I got
there what I also didn't go until 10th
grade but both my my sister went I'd
already paved the way and so she
actually started I believe in 9th grade
you would you had given your parents the
dress rehearsal or not the dress
rehearsal but the sort of debutante ball
with all the fears and concerns probably
not probably not a metaphor but that's
ok see you have you've you've written a
lot and and I want to look at your
master bibliography I'm looking for the
writer squid land of a discography but
your your your books to date and key in
on some of the phrases that are used and
will lead up to the current day so
warped passages subtitle unraveling the
mysteries of the universe's hidden
dimensions can you explain why the title
and subtitle of that book I can try so
um you know it's actually very funny
because um I rich I was gonna call my
original thought for a title was extra
dimensions are you in or out
which
that was next so I had to think of
another title and like I thought what
passages I'm it actually is a joke that
really no one gets so warped comes from
the edge so take the science term warp
comes from the idea of what happened in
that particular geometry with additional
dimension of space that I looked at so
the book is framed around ideas the
extra dimension of space beyond the free
that we see and warped refers to the
fact that things get scaled differently
in a different dimension the city I
don't get resized so warps passages was
a little bit of a joke because it was
the first book I was writing so I was
sort of making fun of I was just joking
about writing so with like four passages
in the spatial sense um you know it
could have many interpretations I mean
like my friend looked at her she's like
oh is that your autobiography yes
everything a joke is very kind of like
does your editor have any idea that that
was an inside joke um no no but I know
that I was told that the marking
Department got hold of it and said can't
you just call the book extra dimensions
and I was like no i couldn't find had a
very interesting title but i spent a
month trying to think of a better title
and i realized you know it actually wore
passages grateful and people really
liked it so I was very happy I kept up
but I did think because it was this sort
of nondescript title or at least could
be interpreted differently I had to
explain at least in a subtitle what
wasn't so it really is about unravelling
mysteries
you know the hidden dimensions both in
terms of dimensions of space but
dimensions sort of metaphorically
understanding what's really out there
underlying the universe so you know
there's a lot of thought take title as
well and when we talk about hidden
dimensions I'd love to hear you just
elaborate on that a little bit because
for instance and we're not we're not
going to dwell on this but I'm reading
for the first time and embarrassed it's
the first time I'm reading it but the
Time Machine by HG Wells and in the
beginning there's a cocktail
conversation and the time traveller is
asking people how many dimensions a cube
exists in and they say three and he says
well actually it's four because can a
cube exist for an end
right and then we get into this
discussion of of time and whatnot but in
in and that only further piqued my
curiosity and interest in chatting with
you but when we're talking about hidden
dimensions could you elaborate on what
you mean by that so when we talk about
dimensions we have to be careful to
distinguish dimensions of space enough
of time um Einstein talked about space
and time is there pressure then in some
sense there is a concept of space-time
geometry for example but space and time
are actually different so when we talk
about a fourth dimension we might mean
time but we can also mean a fourth
dimension of space and when I talk about
a fourth dimension of space you might
say where is it what is it and obviously
it's hidden we see three dimensions of
space up down throw it backward left
right but we don't observe that fourth
dimension and that could be either
because it's really tiny and hidden from
us you might think of a wire that looks
one-dimensional even though we know in
reality there's more dimensions but
we're not resolving those necessarily
and in the same way space can have tiny
fitting dimensions but my collaborator
Raman syndrome and I discovered still
another way than extra dimension could
be hidden and that's because faith is so
warp space-time can be warped and that's
actually what gave rise to the title of
the book four passages and the idea is
that gravity varies so much across an
extra dimension of space that its
strength is so small far away from some
location that this it looks as if
there's only three dimensions even
though there can be a fourth even
infinite dimension them
it's just that in some sense gravity
doesn't leak out into it it stays
concentrated in three dimensions okay I
I'm going to I'm tempted to ask about
interstellar but I might do that later
okay
have you seen interstellar the movie no
no that was that was not the question
yeah come back dude so the the next book
knockin on heaven's door how physics and
scientific thinking illuminate the
universe in the modern world so both of
those are New York Times
you know New York Times 100 notable
books I'm most interested here in the
title why knocking on heaven's door you
know that was it's a good question and
um as anyone who read my first book
knows I am have this mind that I record
you know sort of remember song lyrics
titles and so obviously play in the
words well you know it's interesting you
could tell someone's age by whether they
say Bob Dylan guns and roses or they
think about dying when I say I hear that
title and so it's um it what I wanted to
express was the way science builds on
itself I know it sounds like we're doing
it but the idea is that there's a whole
body of knowledge that we have but we
want to get to the edges we want to say
how can we expand on what we know and go
beyond so sort of so that I like the
idea of knocking in heaven's door sort
of a way of opening beyond the stuff
that we know into the realm of the
unknown but in a way that's so close to
what we know who put the off it improves
upon it and also it was a time when
science and religion got discussed a lot
so I do actually talk about in this book
not just the particular science I do
particle physics in the Large Hadron
Collider but it was also interested in
just explaining what science really is I
felt like neither side sort of with
giving it completely a good enough
extension that they could talk to each
other and I think I I feel like I did a
good job because um when I gave it to
scientific people when I gave it to
religious people neither one was
completely happy so I feel like I had in
fact I gave it to someone to run from
the MIT person parish and he said he
freaking read one of my chapters and he
said I hate to admit it but you're
making a lot of sense here and that was
the one I was looking for that was the
target I was looking for so what was the
the in this case was a definition of
science that provoked that response or
was it it wasn't some sense I think we
have this idea that you know when we
understand the fundamental nature of
things will understand everything and
one of the notions that I really focused
on in this book which i think is a
really useful measure for people to take
away and I'm not sure I'll be able to do
it justice in the
brief time but the idea that an
effective theory the idea that you know
what you can see but you don't
necessarily know what underlies that so
let me give you an example so Newton's
laws work very well they work very well
over a definite regime and unless you
get extraordinarily precise you won't
realize that quantum mechanics or
relativity are actually more fundamental
than Newton's laws so I'd like to think
you know I remember when I learned in
high school about Newton's laws I said
and then they was told that they're not
really right I thought why are they
teaching it to us well they're teaching
it because it is right but it's right in
the sense of being an effective theory
and it's right in the regime that we do
it if you if I want to predict how to
throw a ball or even how to send a
rocket to the moon Newton's law is fine
it's just that if I get into the scale
of an atom then I'm going to need to use
quantum mechanics so I'd like this idea
that science builds on itself it doesn't
mean the other theories are wrong but it
means they're effective theory if they
work over a certain regime and the
reason it's important relates the other
dis confession sometimes people will
think well this can't be right will
never answer certain questions but
that's not true you still need the
fundamental elements of matter even if I
don't yet understand how the brain works
I know fundamentally if there are atoms
involved and there are photons it's
communicating electrical forces involved
it doesn't mean I know all the answers
yet and it might be that I'll have to
look at it at some higher level to get
those answers but it doesn't mean
science can't tackle it but it's
tackling it systematically in previous
effective theory idea and so I've read
that your research has at its heart and
I'm quoting here the search for
fundamental connections in the universe
can you explain what that means well
that's the most recent book where I'm
looking for those is that were you're
referring to yeah so and I thought I
could set that up by saying you know a
comet struck 66 million years ago that
wiped out the dinosaurs and 2/3 of life
on the planet what happened that was my
alternative let's first say that the
title is dark matter and the dinosaurs
and the subtitle
the interconnectedness of the universe
and it refers to both those things there
refers to the research I'm doing where
we'll we'll get back to you which is
dark matter
connecting possibly to the extinction of
the thing but the astounding
interconnected universe was a little bit
um about there's sort of two things I
really wanted to get across in this book
you know obviously my research but but
also how the different fields of science
relate how cosmology the evolution of
the universe the Big Bang Theory
inflation and dark matter those ideas
can connect onto our solar system our
galaxy and then our solar system and our
solar system and how we have an active
solar system with comets and meteoroids
and how those could be related to life
and life's extinction so all these
amazing continuity is sort of how this
all evolved but also how these basic
elements like how nuclear forces can be
relevant for driving plate tectonics
which is drilled into the carbon cycle
which as you know is relevant to life
just these amazing connections that
exist in the universe how heavy elements
were formed in supernovae you know just
all of these different connections
between fun I was very excited because I
studied fundamental particles as I
talked about earlier on but that's not
it's very hard it's abstract hard to
grasp but then I can make this concrete
connection the things that we do
experience in our daily lives and of
course dark matter and the dinosaurs
reserve the ultimate about soils the
Dark Matter might ultimately connect to
something as fundamental though thanks
to the dinosaurs web I just fundamental
to our work but it's important to us
which allowed for four large mammals to
dominate and eventually us so I think
that these connections and understanding
the role always in play how dark matter
helped form galaxies all of these things
that we think of it's so abstract so
what are their concrete manifestation
what are they
was important and the other is sort of
even bigger or less and in some senses
you know just just kind of our history
the planets history life's history at
some level and just how long it took to
get here and what are the different
things that
and just the amazing connections that
were necessary amazing features that
when necessary fall out that happen and
I think it's especially relevant in
light of the rapidity with which we're
changing the planet today
you know it's since the Industrial
Revolution group we've had enormous
changes to the planet and before we do
it I wanted to just just to understand
what that means
so to understand the context and what
what are the things that got us here and
what it would mean to maintain it so I'm
going to ask you about dark matter and I
have some some quotes that I really
enjoyed related to that but first could
you explain the relationship with the
thief I guess it's geological tie in
with mountains and what was it nuclear
decay well so so we I think most of us
now know about plate tectonics which was
actually developed relatively frequently
from the idea that the plates are moving
and then over over the mantle right
which is liquid and what drives that
what gives you the heat it's the fact
that there's nuclear decay and nuclear
decays are providing the heat that
drives this motion and of course as you
know plate tectonics has given rise to
mountain ranges when things crash
together or when they disappear so and
volcanoes and so all of this dynamic
stuff that's happening is being fueled
by its partially by nuclear decay so
that's kind of an amazing connection and
it also the carbon cycle is coming
important this in rincón securin Waltons
thank you I I became very interested in
dark matter and dark energy about I want
to say six months ago when I read an
article called a first glimpse of the
hidden cosmos which is written by
Timothy Ferriss the different Timothy
Ferriss with one s oh that's really
funny okay if you he's a great guy that
was the National Geographic if you could
extend to him my sincerest apologies for
creating so many issues for him on
Google because
everyone misspells my name so I've just
created a huge amount of noise related
to his name inadvertently and I feel
terrible about it I think I live a few
miles from him so in any case I'd love
to take him out for coffee sometime and
apologize in person which I tried to do
with except I tried to track him down at
this Exploratorium event to apologize in
person but I didn't find him in any case
there are a couple of quotes in there so
one of them was and this is this is has
some ellipses at the beginning but the
most profound mystery in all of science
that's astrophysicists Michael Turner on
dark energy empty space is not empty
that's John Archibald wheeler and then
the article ended with scientists are
confronted by the embarrassing fact and
there I'm taking some stuff out but the
embarrassing fact thought that thought
that this is the largest disparity
between theory and observation in the
entire history of science and I was like
wow that's a very strong comment and a
very of course exciting comment in a way
what is what is dark matter how does it
relate to what let's start with what is
dark matter what is dark energy
how are people misusing those terms I
mean it I would love to just hear from a
pro which you are like what how should
we think of these things well you know
it's funny because we've given them
these names that make them sound
mysterious and exotic and even ominous
so the first matter is matter which is
to say it interacts with gravity like
matter it clumps together like in two
galaxies for example but what makes it
dark and actually I'm going to come back
to that named dark which I think it's
very misleading is that it does not
interact with light that is to say if
light hits dark matter it just passes
through in fact billions of dark matter
particles are passing through it every
second but we just don't know about them
because they interact so feebly they
interact gravitationally with us but so
far as we know they do not interact with
light and this comes back to the word
dark which I think might have been
better called transparent matter because
after all we see things that are jar
they absorb light
but we don't see dark matter because it
just lights just doesn't attract of it I
mean there's a hope that there's a tiny
interaction that will help us find it
but so far we've seen no observational
evidence of that so it really is just
matter and that's it it's interesting
there's about five times the amount of
energy carried in stork matter as
ordinary matter which and you know most
people find it interesting because they
think well are you telling me that most
of the matter in the universe isn't the
stuff we're made of but I think I have
exactly the opposite points of view
I'm amazed that and we're just random
why should we be a substantial fraction
of the matter in the universe as we are
in fact why should these to be
comfortable at all if they're only
interacting via gravity you might have
imagined that there was a trillion times
the amount of dark matter or a trillion
times Allah cannot assert that yet the
amounts are remarkably comfortable and
we actually think that might help us
that might ultimately be a clue as to
what dark matter actually is and by that
just to be clear it's not quite as
embarrassing as everyone is saying I
mean there's actually observational
evidence through gravity that this Dark
Matter exists it does influence them it
does have gravitational effect affects
the motions of stars that effect the
motions of galaxies themselves so we're
really more the trajectories of comets
or asteroids it can also affect their
column but so it's not that we haven't
measured dark matter we've measured it
we just don't know fundamentally what
this and by that I mean like is it a
particle so they have a certain mass so
they'd have any interactions at all and
coming back to affecting comets
my proposal with my collaborators is
that maybe most of the Dark Matter
doesn't have any interesting
interactions other than gravity but
maybe a small fraction say five percent
does interact and maybe it even has like
its interactions with its own light just
like Dark Matter doesn't see our light
maybe this mad
Dark Matter has lights that we don't see
and if that's true it too might have
formed but just just like the Milky Way
form to do some ordinary matter forms
note the way this and maybe the effect
of that dark matter gravitational force
is when the solar system comes through
it to actually trigger comics right and
we can talk more about that of the way
well there are so many things I want to
talk about I know where we have some
time constraints but there was there's
another I'm not sure where I picked this
up exactly but I it came up in
association with your name somehow and I
wanted to ask since I'm a bird getting
outside of the earth and talking about
different phenomena but looking at the
our galaxy why are the outer planets in
our solar system bigger than those
closer to the Sun well it's gonna have
to do with the heat of the Sun so if
you're too close to the Sun things like
hydrogen are just going to evaporate so
the inner planets are rocky they're made
of silicon and things like that but
there isn't as much of it other stuff
that the inner planets are made up of so
what there is gets gets trust um but
that's it that's it um the outer planets
are made up of much more abundant
materials like hydrogen and they're
there frizam so it's it's there and then
this outer region where the frozen so we
talked about the rocky inner planets and
the frozen outer planets and there's a
lot more of that stuff
and so that stuff can can grow to a much
bigger size got it
so there are
there are a couple questions I'd love to
ask about distortions or miss
applications of physics and I would love
to hear kind of what are some common I
would say old wives tales but they're
not really old wives tales misuses of
physics that make you cringe so for
instance whether that's people
misunderstanding spooky action at a
distance people say everything has its
frequency there's a lot of kind of
whoo-whoo stuff out there I'm gonna turn
off half your audience perfect
I can't stand the way people use energy
I mean anything they want energy is very
specific and there's many different
forms of energy but for example energy
is conserved so it's nothing we just
talked about the energy of an object or
if the energy is passing through the
energies room or I have good energy or
bad energy it's in physics it's a brick
it really has a different meaning and it
can be converted to mass it can you
convert to other forms of energy but it
really means something very specific and
in common usage energy is used all over
the place for whatever anyone wants it
to
so in physics what would the definition
look like then of energy
it's a conserved quantity so if you have
a different certain energy it will stay
the same that sounds like it sounds like
a tricky one it's kind of like IQ is
that which is measured by an IQ test
yeah that wasn't a great definition I
will grant you I mean I can give it the
problem is the definitions are far too
technical so I'm trying to think of one
that I can section we can come back to
that's not a big deal
so energy anything else come to mind
that just drives you nuts well it's a
little bit unfair to say this drives me
nuts but there are some questions that
come up again and again like
if the universe is expanding what is it
expanding into the answer is it's not
expanding into anything
the universe is all there is stuff is
just getting bigger so you can use an
analogy if you were to willing to them a
balloon with all there is I realize a
balloon is blowing up in a room but
imagine the balloon is all there is and
just draw points on the surface of the
blue when you blow up that balloon those
points will get further apart so even
though the balloon is all there is
it's getting bigger and that's the way
the universe gets bigger it's all there
is but it is getting thicker another
misconception is that um you know the
dark matter doesn't make sense but what
but I think dark matter is probably one
of the most simple modifications of the
physics we know it's just saying that
there's some matter that doesn't
interact with light and why should all
matter interact with light and after all
you know the matter we know how it is
made up of atoms and which which do
interact with light or at least made up
of stuff that's charged namely protons
and electrons so why should all matter
be made up of protons and electrons why
can't there be other types of matter
that don't interact with light um so
that's another one and I think there's
also just this level of which um you
know it's almost people almost full
sometimes prefer further magic notion
and understanding you know I mean one of
the things I do my books do this I ate
so dough I'm just trying not to make it
seem exotic and not to make it seem
overly mystical just to fade this is
what we mean by this and it's not
necessary I think you think it's easy
I'm sorry I don't use the word spooky
magical you know just I just think what
is what it means sunshine well I also it
makes me recall a conversation that I
believe it was either it was in one of
Richard Feynman's either lectures or I
think might have been in the joy of
finding things out which was done by
Nova fantastic interview with him a
profile of him and he talked about a
debate with an artist friend of his who
said that since
Fineman was able to break down this
flower into its physical components down
to the atomic and subatomic levels that
lost the beauty that he couldn't
appreciate the true beauty and he argued
exactly the opposite that it had sort of
provided a framework through which she
could better appreciate the flower in
fact either and in fact in knocking
heaven's door when it back to this
notion of effective theory it's sort of
different ways looking so one it so I
actually talked about music and I talked
about music because you can understand
that the oscillations of air in in your
ears but you get processed by your brain
and then you can understand what music
is at a totally different level and I
would say that's sort of effective
theory you're using different ways of
describing it different promise you
won't even use the same words
necessarily because you're talking about
it at a different level
yes fundamentally for there to be music
I need that I need those I need air I
need those oscillations I need to be
able to process it in my brain but I
don't think that comes anywhere near
describing what music is and I think no
one is actually going to be able to
describe what music is I mean you can
functionally say what this but what it
means to me as a person is going to be
described in a totally different level
and that doesn't negate the physics
interpretation it's just that I don't
think it's fully qualifies as it's
claiming it either mm-hmm that makes
sense this is going to be a bit of a
shift of gears but and this may be right
alongside what is the universe expanding
into a question that bugs you but I'm
gonna risk it is the flow of time I
probably specialize in them but is the
flow of time and illusion you know I
actually think the flow of time is very
real and I might even be the way we
define what time is I mean you know it's
funny when I wrote my first book I
realized that it was able to come up
with you know some of them are difficult
and complex but it's able to come up
with an intuitive explanation of almost
all the concepts you know so you know
the whole goal is to describe it without
map
time is really difficult to
fundamentally explain what is the
difference between time and space I mean
in technical terms in the space time
metric that you do measurements there's
a different sign but that doesn't tell
you anything about intuitively about
what this and I think timing IRA denture
to say that we don't fully understand
yet what time is put in some time
one thing time definitely seems to be is
something we measure as things evolved
as things change
oh as as it possible so I would say that
it's almost essential to describe what
you see what you said in the beginning I
don't remember the exact for it to be
are there any if that question buck me
it only both me but if you don't
understand time any better than we do
hmm are there any particular physicists
or scientists looking researching time
or who have unique perspectives on time
you know so you're not doing predictable
theories and she can come up with ideas
of time backwards or forwards or how it
works I think there is a meaning I'd say
the most interesting things have to do
with them probably the idea of you know
there was something called it is
connected to cosmology and what defines
the universal and forward and maybe
cosmological inflation in the beginning
there were things that happened as over
time very quickly something called
potentially increased a lot which is
sort of how much how many degrees of
freedom Noah right so I think there is
interesting work trying to understand
what what's in inflation you know was
doing in how it really started but again
it borders on philosophy is there yeah
I've so philosophy has always been it's
sort of a contentious subject for a lot
of people but now you have artificial
intelligence and sort of utilitarian
philosophers being brought in to help
people to write code so let's say an
autonomous vehicle has to choose between
hitting to schoolchildren or five
grandmas which does it choose etc I mean
some of these previous
some of these thought exercise
limited's like freshman philosophy
seminars are suddenly becoming relevant
is are there aspects of philosophy that
are becoming more relevant to the to
physics
or is that not the case that's an
interesting question
you know sometimes philosophy helps just
frame what might be an interesting
question but then this is going to go
ahead during it the way it does it um
there are some interesting discussions
like I said on kind of topics that we
don't fully understand so it's really in
the regime where you know you can
question whether we're really making
progress in physics I think in the realm
of moral philosophy I think there I
think that's probably one of the areas
where philosophy is I don't know if I'd
say advanced but I think it's a really
interesting area because there are
interesting moral questions that we do
have to address you know and a lot of
the rapid changes that are happening
today um in terms of philosophy of
physic you know one of the chapters in
my new book dark matter and the
dinosaurs when I talk about cosmology I
first have a chapter on the big question
and I sort of define as philosophy the
questions that everyone wants to know
the answer to do but that we don't
really have definite answers to it
doesn't mean people can't think about
them but it's questions that we might
not have set especially resolved
questions like you know what was there
before the Big Bang or you know what was
the big thing so there are a lot of
question you know why do we have
something rather than nothing although I
do have a tentative answer to that one
well let's come back to that yeah or we
can do right now
I mean why why something rather than
nothing that's big well well my answer
is first of all you can't ask the
question unless there was something but
also in my mind at least nothing is a
very unlikely possibility if you think
about it a zero and a number line is
very very unlikely and if there isn't if
you do happen to get there's usually a
reason for it and that also means there
is something so it's just very hard from
ever to nothing at least for me as being
the most
we focus in something is much more
likely I Joseph it you know you always
find what you're looking for but usually
find something yeah yeah it brings up
all sir I mean I won't take us off the
rails but it's it's great this this I
think we'll do a round two with more
wine
the I was chatting with a mutual friend
of ours and she said that you and she
have discussed the idea of how science
can expand empathy and our ability to
see beyond ourselves and I don't want to
put words in your mouth but if that's
the case could you elaborate
well it's something I you know I use a
lot of analogies in the book to relate
to that when I talk about dark matter I
thought that other things I'm actually
for those who are interested I haven't
out there coming out in the Boston Globe
about this and the idea is that it's
difficult constituents plan so let's
bear with me let me try to stand where
this easier to write almost but you know
when we do physics when people you know
it's sort of almost a reaction when I
talk about particle physics and things
that are removed from our everyday
students I taught a Freshman Seminar
through even the students recognize
things that are removed from our
everyday experience we tend to think of
as less real or less important so if I
talk about a cork or the Higgs boson
you're at you know the erection is
that's kind of interesting but who cares
at some level that's not what we're in
counseling or do it but if you're at the
scale of a corker thinks boson that's
really important and you know we're made
of ordinary matter so we tend to think
of dark matter is not that important but
there's five times as much of it and
furthermore it gave rise to the
development account it helped develop
galaxies so it's really relevant to the
universe and you know we do the same
thing in sort of social purpose you know
that we could forget the masses who are
building buildings will remember the
leaders or the architects but we forget
the people who led to the construction
will look at our hearts society but will
think of us other societies this and
lesser in some way because they're not
ours and if you're in another society
then you
I think yours is primary so I think it
is you have to get outside that
perspective I think in science you all
know that we have to get outside that
perspective we're never going to
understand things or the scale of the
universe for that matter we have to
allow ourselves to think of it and I
think the same thing applies to social
interactions as well that you really
have to imagine a different perspective
to fully understand that well I think
that its immediate seems like it does no
it doesn't make sense it seems to me
that being a scientist fundamentally
among other things or having putting
putting in a different way using the
scientific method or thinking
scientifically involves among other
things forming hypotheses and
recognizing their hypotheses testing
those hypotheses but also being aware of
and/or testing your assumptions right so
I think that and and the kind of meta
skill I suppose on top of all that or
one of them is being observant and
noticing the kind of invisible or trying
to notice the minut where things don't
quite fit together and be and and taking
them seriously that's absolutely right
what is the difference but also know I'm
sorry go ahead what is it and also
sometimes it's you know having a first
perspective I mean you know when we
found the existence of an extra
dimension of space was helpful we were
coming at it from particle physics we
weren't people who do primarily
generative 'ti in fact we were told that
that's impossible because there was
theorem saying it was well um but
because we've come at it from a
different direction we sort of if I'm
sorry accidentally discovered a solution
that we can then go back and see where
and where the fundamental assumption was
wrong with what had been missed and you
know the work we're doing on dark matter
now this idea that there could be of
dark matter just and it could affect
astronomy come back and because we were
trying to understand some observation
that could have been a dark matter
because we were so coming at it from a
different direction so we weren't no
small numbers and so sometimes it helps
to have some come in a few different
perspectives but to be open to what the
people in the field say of course but to
really take his balance all these
different points of view
I have to ask you about interstellar I
can't I can't forget what did you think
of interstellar I think there's an
interesting experiment
the idea was science that was possible
not necessarily likely but never to have
anything that couldn't that we knew
couldn't happen I think that was a
little less I think it was really
admirable to have the characters take
fine so seriously to try to talk science
I mean not saying I loved all the
dialogue but I think it was really
interesting to me one of the things I
felt well it's interesting that was to
treat science as if it's just part of
everyday vocabulary right and that I
really liked it wasn't taken as some
other thing was just part of their daily
lives so I think there was some really
interesting I'd stance that were
explored in that movie I I really I had
heard so many skin sort of criticisms of
the movie and I didn't dig into the
details and I really enjoyed it so that
that's that I'm not sure why I felt it
necessary to proclaim that but the the
here's a here's a kind of a wacky
question maybe I know and I'll start
with just an observation and an
observation is that if I talk to
neuroscientists particular particularly
people who are not say behavioral or
cognitive focused but those who are
really focused on neuroanatomy and look
at lesions and the effects of lesions
and so on they they tend not to believe
in the afterlife I've had the opposite
experience with physicists or something
after sort of consciousness after
physical death I know this is getting
out there but am I totally off-base
there I mean do do but I think part of
what the success is how things are tied
up to their physical makeup I mean that
is the potential it doesn't mean we
undressed
damn that doesn't mean we understand how
everything fits together to give you
consciousness or whatever it is that
constitutes a person but that physical
stuff is really important now you know I
should say you know I've been in tricky
situations where you know I really feel
for people because you know working on
an extra dimension of space or talking
about physics people really want to
believe these things you know or you
know uh you know they'll be
heartbreaking so we'll say into my
sister died really young that you know I
think she's in the next image but you
know I'm very sympathetic to their
desire to believe it and to want to
believe these things Christmas you know
they certainly persist in our memory but
I personally think that things are tied
to the physical reality doesn't mean I
over estimate my understanding of it I
don't know that connection I don't know
how it works but I do think that the
fundamental physical reality is
essential and if you have a question
about that here's Secours one question I
have which is sort of you know how as a
scientist might approach from you know
my mother passed away a couple years ago
and and she really did injure her brain
as there should become a very different
person so like where is the person in
that if you really want to believe that
there is an afterlife what happened to
the person in that state where they're
still alive but they've really hurt
themselves right I mean it's a horrible
reality to face and it's a horrible
thing to watch but I think that's the
kind of question if you really want to
believe that you have to be able to
answer those questions absolutely yes
it's a very tough question I mean this
is I've had Sam Harris on the podcast
before and he brings us up in I'm sure
he's written about it but he's also
brought it up in discussions on this
very topic
he has no shortage of debates with
religious folks as you might imagine let
me ask a question right no understood
the so I have a question from a reader
this is from Mary Grace and if this
question is too time-consuming to answer
then you can you can pass but here
here's her comment I studied pure math
in college and one of our favorite
things to do was debate with the
theoretical physicists
whose major was crazier of course we
each thought the others was crazier I'd
like to hear her description of an
object example a tennis ball as it moves
through additional dimensions of space
fourth that tennis ball things because
the test boat that I know are made of of
students that I know they've been three
dimensions so could it be that so one of
the things I talked about in more
passages yeah idea of what's called a
brain theory any I'm sorry again a brain
CRA any which is say could be say a
three-dimensional surface in higher
dimensional space so maybe it's as
boring as the ball just stays in the
three dimensions of the brain
if the ball wants to get off the brain
it has to be made of something that can
exist in those other dimensions but we
have very serious observational
constraints of what the extra dimensions
can look like so I think my so I'm going
to take the cop-out solution that's it
right now which is not crazy at all and
just say if there is an X dimension the
tennis ball might not be going that got
it okay let's talk about what is these
significance what is and what is the
significance of the Higgs boson um so I
actually wrote I'm the one I wrote me
but cause I hate discovery mm-hmm where
I try to discuss it because it I have to
say where I wrote my first book like the
Higgs boson sorry one of the hardest
things to explain so let me just give
you a couple of answers first of all the
Higgs boson is evidence experimental
evidence that our theory of how
particles acquire their mouth is correct
so the actual way particles get their
mass is not from the expose on itself
which is a particle but from something
called Biggs mechanism which involves
something called the field so these are
all different so it's a little confusing
but the idea is in some sense to try to
give a just a sense of what it's saying
is that throughout space there's like a
Higgs charge
actual particles for like a charge and
particles that get mess through the
Higgs mechanism essentially interact
that charges so there and ones that are
heavier interact more ones that are
lighter in fact less the Higgs boson is
connected to that field that's spread
throughout space so the Higgs boson
interacts with heavier particles more
forth lighter particles less and so it
does two things for us and scientists it
tells us first of all the idea of the
Higgs mechanism is in fact collapsed and
it also gives us some idea of what it
was that produced that charge cousin
Berkeley it tells us nothing called the
Higgs field which is what spread
throughout space so the discovery of the
Higgs boson really tells us how
elementary particles and by elementary
particles I mean things like quartz and
electron how they get them out they
don't just have mass than the Gecko if
they did the theory would make totally
nonsensical predictions like
probabilities of interactions at high
energies being greater than one it
really required some sort of mechanism
and that mechanism is the sneaks
mechanism having to do with this time
service charged by that space if SC was
really confusing it's because it is it's
hard to understand um without really
going through all the math of it but
that's essentially the essence of what's
going on and and now that that has been
verified what's the what's the biggest
thing the sort of the number one that
physicists are looking to verify yeah
those people who really study what's
happening at Large Hadron Collider are
looking forward to understanding two
things if we're lucky one is mad so the
question of why is the Higgs map what it
is without something else around we
would actually expect it to be like 16
orders of magnitude heavier like
ridiculously heavy but we know that's
not the case and we know what the Higgs
boson masses the question is what else
is there and so it turns out the answer
to that question involves some very
exotic
I do like extra symmetries of space or
or this idea of an extra dimension of
space I talked about the other thing
that people hope we might get some
insight into has to do with dark matter
a creepy that are a Dark Matter particle
can be produced at the Large Hadron
Collider if one of these ideas about
what's going on with Enix math is
correct we don't know that's the case
but searchers are going on to see
whether we can deduce Dark Matter at the
watch I collided well mm-hmm have
another question from a fan it's from
Peter Shaw and I'm gonna slightly adapt
this and paraphrase it but the the
question his question I think is and you
may have partially you know I am
fascinated by physicists in inverse
proportion to how much I know about it
so it's like I know so little about
physics I'm but I'm endlessly fascinated
by it
because I admire I admire some of the
precision and I also admire the
willingness to deal with messy problems
yeah so I I'm trying to make up for lost
time but yeah you know during my summer
program when I was supposed to be
studying physics I fell in love with
this Turkish girl and that was kind of
the end of my physics but the so the
question from Peter Shaw sorry I was
lost in reverie for a second is why did
why does research into cosmology matter
theoretical physicists are brilliant but
most modern ones seem to be interested
in the cosmos to the layman he can't see
the direct benefit of this research
here's the question I have for this
matter I mean I think nothing matters
more than sort of understanding what's
going on what the universe is made of
how we got here yes you know we can
maybe find ways to cure the beam and
live another day we can find perhaps new
sources of energy from
able to power our gadgets more so I mean
and that's all fun and it's certainly
enjoyable and we think of that as a
purpose but there's another purpose
which is just to really learn things
understand things value things pop
culture sees human beings and so I know
that for many people that might not be
the most satisfactory answer and to
those people I can remind you that the
most basic science we didn't know what
the implications or applications would
be at the time and that doesn't just
apply to v funny I can guarantee that
Watson and Crick we're not trying to
solve cancer when they were exploring
DNA right that's a great example matters
and it comes down to help us and also
gets people excited about science it
gets serious I don't think it's
coincidence the place of sort of great
science also have good economy there's
health care you know this there's
correlations and it's because people who
value these things are valuing what's
important and it's so our mutual friends
also brought up and I wanted to your
help defining these terms that sometimes
you're frustrated about getting people
to value basic science versus kind of
the sexiness of Applied Science
could you just define those two I mean I
could take a stab at it but it would be
sloppy what is the difference between
basic science and appliances also basic
sciences you know trying to understand
DNA without trying to understand can it
be useful I mean what what will it do
for me tomorrow
I'm applied science there's more thing I
want to solve in these I want to fill
the computer oh you know cool quantum
mechanics some help with the development
ultimately gave rise or a transfer in
some sense through semiconductors but
people I can assure you people working
on quantum mechanics we're not thinking
about an iPad they were thinking about
trying to understand how the atom could
make them or how radiation to make them
and so it's really basic five is just
trying to understand how to make sense
of what the world is made of how to make
sense of how things work
subscribe science is trying to see
answer the question of your listener the
leader
can can you use this to make my life
better tomorrow
well you know it's it's in an odd way I
do a lot in the tech world there's
there's a there are comparable
differences among entrepreneurs or tech
builders you have people who try to
determine a market or market size a
total addressable market blah blah blah
and then build for that which would be
the I suppose the equivalent of Applied
Science and then you have the person
who's just scratching their own itch and
that may be for a particular need or one
but it could also just be out of
curiosity and the most important
curiosity a great thing I mean yeah it's
just what makes the world work near you
it's so good
totally agree oh yeah totally agree I
all right so let's let's completely
switch gears if you don't mind and I
would love to ask you a number of
questions that I love to ask the first
is when you think of the word successful
who's the first person who comes to mind
and why people out there who are just
very happy with what they're doing it's
hard because people I know always are
looking for more so I don't I'm sorry I
just don't have one okay well I'll be
taking a different angle Oh No
if you only knew if you only knew but
well I should say the same of you on a
much larger scale which month with much
bigger questions but the went in the
last five years when have you felt the
most successful oh that's interesting
um you know I do think that um when you
have you know even those little things
where things tend to click where we have
some idea that you know is going
somewhere you when we developed this
idea of doba this or that it was very
exciting I don't know that I'm kathiria
successful
very satisfied which was this I'm sorry
I'm sorry
the idea of historic matter that we're
looking at fit does have these
interactions that can form a disc inside
the Milky Way that could be denser it
was really really interesting to put
that all together and to realize this
really did make sense and was something
that was relatively unexplored it was
really exciting um you know when I'm
writing a book
I feel successful when I get the idea to
match you know you sort of have a vision
of what you want to be saying through a
vision of how you want to fit together
and get some rather complicated ideas
across and so when I've done that to my
satisfaction way that I find beautiful
and enjoyable I feel like that's a
success also when I'm doing a long five
minutes and I you know do this fun that
I thought was going to be too hard
I feel good that's all yeah it's sort of
these little achievements that make me
feel happy and I wish we had more time
to dig into the rock climbing but we'll
have to save that for a follow-up
the as a side note I there's a there's
an interview I just did with a guy named
Jimmy chin and there's a documentary
he's featured in called mehru
if you're into climbing you should
definitely check out marrow it's
incredible yeah it's it's about this
particular climb that has defeated the
top climbers for about 30 years it's
it's fantastic
but the the next question is about books
what is the book that you've given most
as a gift excluding excluding your own
books I second that you know this sort
of books that I'll give to certain young
girls like I really love the book I
capture the castle
oh sure the castle I capture the castle
this place sounds like an odd choice for
me because this I just think it's a
really lovely book about the importance
of art and you just understand the world
and the things around like creative
people it's sort of a young adult book
by dirty stuff but it's just a lovely
book it's called I capture present-tense
the cat awesome I'll check that out you
know I'm the kind of guy who reads it's
a girl's book in some ways yeah you know
it bugs me
the books and I only figured this out
recently are slotted into young adult
not because the books are necessarily
intended for young adults but because
the main characters are young adults I
had no idea it's like the gold yeah like
like the Golden Compass was [ __ ] a young
adult and I had to look up like 300
words in that book to just figure out
the definitions but I'm digressing so I
captured the castle do you have it's not
the right way to start this question
what are your favorite documentaries or
movies that come to mind let me guess
let me let me guess you don't want to
answer it so I'm gonna say kickboxer to
vet it actually forgetting the name but
there was one about the downfall of Wall
Street that was really great oh the
downfall of Wall Street is it too big to
fail is that what you're talking about
the documentary we can come back to that
so here's here's what about purchases
what $100 or less purchase has most
positively impacted your life in the
last six months a year it doesn't really
matter actually what was the first one
sorry no climbing [ __ ] uh-huh what what
are they what kind of climbing shoes
they're just mythos it's just that it
was just really nice to get better so
better again the other is probably like
this out really silly but I got you've
been touched this rock and it just looks
so clean and efficient and it encourages
me that's the meter in my kitchen you
minik touch yeah it's just a really nice
I mean it looks a little bit Spacey but
I just I just like the organization of
it it's just make you feel happy when I
do that no that's that's perfect that's
exactly the kind of thing I'm looking
for what is something you believe that
other people think is insane
if anything
well I don't know people think it's been
saying but like my answer to whether
there's something rather than nothing is
probably a little bit unconventional
here is what okay so the first question
is what is super string theory I guess
the other thing something that I think
the other thing I believe I don't know
people think is insane but I really like
to believe that when people know more
they will make more sensible decisions
and I probably isn't saying because we
don't always have evidence enough but
sometimes you know especially when
trying to explain the kind of science I
do you know people will be like why are
you do I do think that once people
understand things they will value them
more you know it's like at a very
fundamental level this isn't about
knowledge so much but yeah when I first
saw the big redwood forest I understood
oh this is why they want to preserve the
forest you know you can read about the
spotted owl it's like can you actually
go and experience it but also you know
when you see politics day and I feel
like if people really actually had
access to the actual information and not
just represent with one side but really
can get it and that probably isn't
saying because there's a lot of evidence
that's not true but I still would like
to believe that people you know I'd sort
of what drives me to sort of do distance
where you're writing book for commenting
is that when people know more they will
do better place mm-hmm yeah I tend to
agree I here's a question from a
scientist friend of mine lots of
interesting work has been done in large
programs like string theory and loop
quantum gravity that don't yet connect
well to the observable universe near
current energy limits what do we need to
do to get more Mavericks trying
different things I'm not sure I
understand the connection between the
two parts of the question well so his
first part was asked about the great
slowdown in particle theory after the
standard model got finished around
1973-74 specifically why so much energy
been spent on large programs that have
yet to deliver rather than funding
individuals who want to try new things
so that's you know some my reaction is
to try to work on things where you can
make progress and that's why before I
worked on particle foods
you know but now I mean I still work on
particle two from working on dark matter
because I think both theoretically and
observational II in ways that I talked a
lot about in my book I think it's really
poised to make progress I think there's
a lot going on that can teach event and
one of the roles as what I call myself
is a model builder where one of the
roles I have is just new ways to look
for new phenomena so we don't miss
things with the observations that we do
um you know I think but you know the
fact of the matter though in answer to
your question is that scientists are
people just like everyone else you know
everyone likes to see other people doing
what they're doing and they think what
they're doing is the most important so I
think just people have to be more
open-minded I mean one of the amazing
things of you know yes how why did I
send become known it's because I'm
really bright bred to work and realize
it was important it's another question
what establish credit and it was a
breath I think we just have to really
listen to good ideas when I hear
something you know that takes time and
effort
what are common misc
think cysts but what are the most common
misconceptions about you or about your
your field you could take it either way
why do people think you're scary I think
it's because anything that's out of the
norm is sort of initially scary but it's
not like everyone thinks I'm scary but I
think you know you hear there's this
woman businesses but you know whatever I
mean full assume that they sort of some
foreign farm being or something so I
think maybe that there's a little bit of
that probably exaggerating closely but I
do know that like you know people will
misunderstand who I am a lot I think
also I have this annoying feature of
being very for us and I think you know
like I said I wasn't properly socialized
so I didn't learn all the progress of
circumlocutions the niceties of society
yet I came to I just don't like wasting
time so it's like if they were there
it's like I think also you know another
thing is like I can actually argue a
point
about like I can disagree with a person
and still like some it doesn't reflect
on what I'm thinking about the person
the fact that I might disagree with
their point of view and I think that's
also something very foreign to a lot of
people you know people take it
personally my argument and I don't mean
up this law what is superstring theory
but you know it talks about particle
physics before so string theorists think
that the fundamental nature of matter is
not to sell magic particles it's
actually fundamental strings which are
athletes produce the different particles
but that fundamentally is strength not
critical if that really would be a whole
other hour okay all right let me just
because somebody I care a lot about
wanted me to ask because he's genuinely
interested is if super string theory is
not falsifiable does that mean it's not
worth pursuing I would say the answers
that you know which is a double negative
there so I mean I don't think everyone
should work on it but I do think there
are ideas that come out of string theory
even if it itself isn't never like being
toasted so it can be applied to other
types of promise I mean some of the work
that I did on extra dimensions of space
came about because I'm thinking about
ideas from string theory and some of the
implications of our idea reflect on what
can happen in string theory string
theory is also used to understand black
holes for example and eventually there
will be experimental stuff of that so
you might not test the entire theory
that you can have to live it or use it
to come up with methods it's also been
used for now I'm not saying it's the
only thing we should do and I myself
don't consider myself a string theory so
though I don't do stuff at interfaces
for that I prefer to do things that are
more directly connected to experiment so
I would say that you know just like
everything else you know in America we
tend to sort of throw in exchange I
think everyone has to do something
everyone I think if there's a place for
it it should be everyone can make it is
a place where if you could have one
billboard anywhere with anything on it
what would it say be curious
my sister comes be curious do you think
you can train curiosity I get for like a
school curriculum is there is there a
way that we could better instill or
foster creativity and some are curiosity
excuse me in some way well that's a good
question and I think a lot of it has to
do you know when people ask questions
taking the question seriously I mean
that can be tedious and it's not all I
mean not every question is a good
question but sometimes you know people
will ask questions and they'll get cut
off or they'll be ignored and it tends
to make you not want to ask questions so
I think you know basically you don't
have to listen to each other and if
people listen together they'll get more
great and also be given opportunities
pop needs to explore out the chance to
breathe afternoons to work on problems I
think you know I think people are
naturally curious so the question is not
to get rid of the curiosity right how do
we avoid neutering that curiosity
perhaps just a few more questions what
advice would you give to your 30 year
old self probably don't take yourself
too seriously and place if you don't
mind placing for us that in context what
were you doing at 30 or where were you
and when you are a PhD student what
advice would you have given yourself
hmm not to take myself quickly seriously
got it aye well this has been so much
fun I have one last and then I'm gonna
point people off no not at all and last
but not least just out of curiosity no
do you have any ask
aside from checking out the book and
everything you do online which we'll do
in a second do you have any ask or
request for my audience that's a good
question um I think you know I'd like to
know you know which explanation that
I've given you know in my books or even
on here
you know people find helpful great they
can do that where can they let you know
um I have a Twitter account um my handle
is actually not least up of Lyra Randall
LIRR and RA ends at the AOL but also you
know in my book I'd like to know if you
know the points come across if people
understand what I'm trying to explain
and also you know these various
analogies like do they get that they
were working at you get them applause
and where can people find you online in
the book besides well besides on Twitter
where where else can people find
accounts enough and I'm actually in the
process of setting up a web account for
the bus to it but the only social media
thing I do is read it right now and
other than that so we'll see a website
soon so just look for a Lisa Rambo or
ordered dark matter in the dinosaurs
website one of them looking wonderful
and guys the book is dark matter and the
dinosaurs subtitled the astounding
interconnectedness of the universe it is
currently number one and it's it's in
paleontology of all things which is yeah
or when you're listening to this it
might have been out for a year or two so
check it we did give that's all part of
our back
the future theme and check it out guys I
have personally made a commitment to get
back into reading more of physics and I
would say if you want to try
psychedelics but aren't going to
actually do it if you want to put on a
new a new lens through which to view
everyday life
so-called ordinary life but gain an
additional perspective this is a great
way to do it
so of course yeah my pleasure entirely I
love this stuff and I need to resolve to
actually learn something about it I know
I got over the Turkish girls very
distracting but I really appreciate the
time and is there anything else you
would like to share before yeah we own
this round one I think that was quite a
lot to share but I'm I just really I
mean I actually really find it rewarding
you know you spend all these time you
know I do research but it's been all
this time we're in the book so it's so
rewarding to me when people really are
interested in do what you want to
understand these things then and that's
that's what I'm writing for so thank you
yeah to me
to me I mean these are some fundamental
and basic aspects of reality that were
but that you and other physicists are
digging into and like you said I've been
Watson and Crick we're not trying to
solve cancer and I think it's easy to
kind of miss the longer-term
implications of a lot of what's being
done and in basic science so I'm really
happy to have you on and everyone
listening you can find the links to
things we've discussed favourite books I
capture the castle etc and everything
else we've talked about including the
book at 4-hour workweek comm forward
slash podcast you can also just go to
4-hour workweek comm all spelled out
click podcasts for the show notes for
this episode and every other episode and
for sir Randall thank you so much for
taking the time thank you so much for
doing this
and everyone listening until next time
thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday the vet provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market if you're anything like me you
care a lot about the food you put into
your body in fact I think it's much more
important than exercise the problem is
that good food can be extremely
expensive but it doesn't have to be a
thrive market which is one of the
fastest growing startups in the health
space right now is like Costco for
everything healthy an online shopping
club offering the best brands and
groceries at 25 to 50% off of retail
prices ship nationally for free it's
awesome there are a ton of slow carb
friendly items that I recommend in the
4-hour body you can easily filter
everything by your preferences whether
you're paleo gluten-free vegan raw
non-gmo vegetarian veterinarian whatever
so go to thrive market calm /cam and
check it out you can get a free two
month trial and 25% off your first order
when you sign up for a membership if you
sign up it's fifty nine ninety five per
year which is only five dollars a month
at the very least go there and check out
the avocado Mayo they have which is
amazing not only that for repaying
member thrive gives a free membership to
a low-income family veteran or teacher
which is awesome and helps level the
playing field so you can get ripped
while you're doing some good also never
pay full price for healthy food again
check it out thrive market.com forward
slash Tim to start your free two month
trial and get 25% off your first order
what a a blues nothing go check it out
avocado Mayo it's read thrive market
calm forward-slash Tim and until next
time thank you for listening